he kicks off nbc sports on peacock's
schedule every single day with pro
football talk live uh and he's got a new
book coming out called playmakers that
everybody should pre-order right now on
amazon where all books are sold just in
time for uh the holidays mike florio
here on the rich eisen show how are you
doing mike i'm doing great rich great to
talk to you as always
right back at you uh any sense about uh
who could be up and down for today while
we uh while we're getting ready for a
doubleheader on monday that we're not
used to having well i know that the
browns were approaching the entire
situation assuming that they weren't
going to get any of the guys back that
have been on covert reserve they had 18
on the active roster as of yesterday
that weren't available and anyone we get
we view it as a bonus now the deadlines
passed john johnson their safety has
made it back no baker mayfield no case
kingdom they won't play they're holding
out hope that maybe kevin stevansky the
head coach will get clearance before
then different rules apply to him than
they do for the rosters i'm surprised
they're still adhering to these strict
roster rules under the circumstances but
they just want to get through the game
today
and the two games tomorrow and then it's
going to be a lot easier with these new
protocols to get the rest of the games
in well i guess if mayfield nor keenum
is playing tonight and that's going to
be the case that
does that make the raiders feel a little
bit better because i know they were
livid about uh this game being pushed
you know it has to yeah it has to make
them feel better that they didn't get
a situation where the two-day delay
enables mayfield to return or keenum
because
the raiders look at it and say we didn't
do anything here we didn't cause this
now it's hard to separate
the unfair
inconvenience of having to play on
monday and turn around and play on
sunday when you were supposed to play on
saturday
and the idea that they just want to get
an easier win and it's hard to fault any
of the teams out there or the fans who
root for the raiders the eagles of the
seahawks
when you're influenced by the fact that
hey we thought we were going to get an
easy win against an overmatched opponent
so
you know there are legitimate reasons
and there are kind of like yeah you know
you just were hoping you were going to
get that easy check the box w
the raiders are going to have an easier
go but with mcmullens playing
quarterback that's for sure and you know
it makes for an interesting game because
there's still plenty of very capable
browns players who are out there and
nobody really knows what to make of the
raiders right now mike florio here on
the rich eisen show so what is the
status of
of the playing games and when to play
games moving forward over the next i
mean we're rubber is now meeting the
road sir as you know there's three weeks
to go there's a lot of saturday games
there's also um you know a playoffs
right around the corner as well so it's
funny that we're running out of time in
the longest regular season ever but that
is the case you know here's what
ultimately happened over the past few
days and i'll put it like this the
castle was being stormed the walls were
being breached by the virus
and
labor and management got together and
they just decided to tear down the walls
i mean that's basically what's occurred
the the the principles underlying the
covet protocols were starting to
interfere with practicality which meant
profit and paycheck at risk as well and
nothing gets
the nfl and the nfl pa together than the
shared threat that they're going to lose
money and that really is what forced it
nflpa leadership was kind of caught in
the middle because they were advocating
a more responsible approach but as
someone explained it to me yesterday the
pandemic is now endemic to society and
with this omicron variant that is
spreading like wildfire and that is not
making very many of the vaccinated
people who get it sick
the only thing to do at this point is
just stop testing the vaccinated
asymptomatic players they're not testing
them except
on a very targeted basis it's hard to
understand it's not quite the same as
the random testing for peds or other
things of that nature and they will test
anyone who's symptomatic or who wants to
be tested you know rich the concern i've
already heard it people are going to
hide their symptoms they're not going to
come in and put their hand up and say i
don't feel right today they're going to
keep their mouth shut they're going to
keep their head low because they want to
play they want to play they want to
coach they want to be available
especially during these critical weeks
of the season so that
introduces even more of the virus in the
building the people really at risk of
the unvaccinated now they can reduce
their risk by getting vaccinated but
there's going to be a lot more virus in
the building now because they're not
going to have that gatekeeping function
that will
keep vaccinated players who are positive
out of the facility so
you know
they're just they're waving the white
towel on this and or waving the white
flag or throwing the towel i'll mix my
metaphors if i damn well please it's
christmas week
but they're giving up they're just
giving up and now if this gets worse
if all of a sudden there's some new
variant that makes people sicker or
something like that they'll pivot but
for now they've just recognized
widespread
virus
low
incident of sickness at least
out of the way at least that's what you
know people are hoping i mean i i i
don't know
you you hear it is just as severe as
delta and god forbid if it is you know
um and i guess we'll find out and i
guess what's happening in the nba and
the nfl is is kind of foreshadowing
potentially what's happening or or
what's happening in real time because
this
this variant seems to be uh having a
doubling rate of of every other day
potentially you know from what you're
seeing
so who knows if if the way that the
approaching the protocols right now will
be operative even next week that is a
fact
right that's right dr sills told peter
king that in today's football morning in
america that they are going to continue
to monitor if it changes again they're
going to have to be ready to pivot but
the goal at this point as i understand
it get through the season and then
figure everything out
after the season but it is amazing to me
rich when you consider that the average
player from the get-go from the moment
that
the pandemic became a thing march 11 of
2020
the
average football player doesn't care
never did care views himself rightly or
wrongly he's impervious to it healthy
enough it's not an issue for me it's way
down on the list of the risks that i
assume when i put on my uniform and my
helmet and go out onto a football field
it's amazing the union
held them together
as long as they did because this mindset
has always been there we don't care we
don't care we don't care and it finally
prevailed because we're getting to a
point where throughout society it's
getting harder and harder to get people
to care and you know here we are holiday
week people traveling people getting
together what do we do
i think there's this widespread belief
and it's crossed over to the nfl that we
just go forward and we see what happens
mike florio pro football talk here on
the rich eisen show
okay so uh
walk me through how jacksonville doesn't
pay urban meyer even though some of the
offenses
absolutely are would stick if it's for
cause if they had actually
fired him at the time of finding out
that josh lambo got kicked even though
they said it really wasn't part of the
timing about firing him or they fired
him within 48 hours of that video of the
you know him being back in ohio after
not taking the team plane like can you
still say that you know what you haven't
taken your finger off the chess piece
and and now you don't pay him is that
possible let's spin the clock shall we
rich back to the year 2005.
we both were a lot younger
you were with the upstart at the time
nfl network i was scrabbling around with
a
a renegade website that didn't know what
the hell it was going to be or where it
was going to go terrell owens
remember what happened with him in the
eagles yes sir when it all blew up and
they suspended him for four games
without pay for conduct detriment with
the team they won that grievance because
they were able to show up for the
hearing with a stack
of documents
that backed up every warning they'd
given him every incident he'd been
involved in every threat that they made
as it relates to
graduated discipline you do something
like this again this is going to happen
you do this again this is going to
happen and they were able to lay out a
clear paper trail that showed that the
last straw really was the last straw not
cover for whatever they wanted to do and
that's the challenge the jaguars are
going to have here they're going to have
to make it
seem to whoever is deciding this and it
very well may be the commissioner so the
dac the deck gets stacked in favor of
the jaguars inherently because the
commissioner works for the jaguars and
the other 31 teams but you need to be
able to show that you're not just
pulling something out of the air and
saying oh yeah
it was because he he kicked the kicker
that was why we fired him for cause
because it's very easy to cross-examine
whoever from the jaguars on the point
that they knew about it in august so how
can it be
the thing that causes you to fire him
for cause four months later when you
knew about it in august how can you say
that his failure to return to
jacksonville with the team after the
september 30th loss to the bengals is
the cause that goes into this because
they kept him around when the dust
settled on that they're going to have to
demonstrate the kind of papering of the
file that's what the in-house lawyers do
when you're not defending your client in
quarter arbitration or whatever you're
making sure that all the eyes are dotted
and tease across so you can justify
doing whatever it is you eventually do
that's going to be the challenge can
they back this up or is it just going to
be this shotgun approach that makes it
look like we just decided we were done
with them and we're going to grab
whatever we can to justify not
paying well you know what man uh there's
so many reasons why the the the
jaguars needed to um separate to me it
was the minute he didn't get on the
plane i've heard that over and over
again i'm wondering in the scuttlebutt
that you hear and talking to everybody
uh what they
is is it being termed the biggest flop
in the history of uh of nfl coaching or
there are there are some defenders that
there was these injuries that the so on
and so forth what do you what do you
think what's being discussed
in the loudest one over the weekend was
jimmy johnson who's
who has a friendship with urban meyer
and of course jimmy johnson is the
anti-urban meyer because he came in
straight out of college and he weathered
the storm and he laid the foundation to
have a strong team but johnson said
yesterday on fox's pregame show that
meyer didn't have his people you know
when jimmy came he came straight from
the university of miami with all of his
people so he had all these other people
and he had quote unquote backstabbers
which means that's what urban meyer is
saying to jimmy johnson when they talk
that he was stabbed in the back it's not
anything he did i mean that's the one
big takeaway from the interview that
meyer did with the n rap report for me
it's not about him it's about fragile
players fragile coaching staff getting
stabbed in the back it's never his own
conduct so look here's the reality two
things one urban meyer has clearly
always been this way the rest of the
world has changed and he hasn't and
number two if they'd been eleven and two
instead of two and eleven he'd still be
there he'd still be there
so you know you can get away with a lot
of crap
if you're winning
and if you're not winning and you're
somebody that the coaching staff doesn't
like and the players don't like they're
not gonna put up with it and before you
know it there's going to be this drip
drip drip that finally results in the
dam breaking and that's what happened
last week but the challenge for the
jaguars now is going to be to piece it
all together in a way that shows that he
doesn't deserve another penny there's an
important factor in this too rich if you
want to make a great hire for your next
coach
you sure don't want that coach when he
does his due diligence to come to the
conclusion that the way they're trying
to screw urban meyer may be the way they
try to screw you in the future and
coaches pay attention to that so if you
have coaches with options and they think
they're walking into a spot where push
comes to shove they're going to try to
stick it to you financially
you may not be inclined to take that job
last one for you mike um mike florio pro
football talk here on the rich eisen
show
the
the new rule where
as of next
tuesday so a week from uh tomorrow
you're allowed to start talking to
candidates for a head coaching position
uh despite the season still going on uh
if they're under contract with other
teams normally you'd have to wait till a
window opens up during the playoffs and
that created a lot of problems for
people who deserved interviews to not
get them
so
does that mean tonight's game is it
possible the loser of tonight's monday
night football game between the vikings
and the bears
uh is out and there's an interim head
coach so
these teams can get a head start that
jacksonville and the raiders already
have is that possible i think i don't
think we understand yet because it
hasn't happened what this is going to do
to the normal
pink slip cycle you know we called it
black monday the day after the regular
season ended and it had trickled back
into sunday just like black friday
trickled into thanksgiving i mean we get
more and more of these firings on the
last day of the regular season as soon
as the final games are over now with the
clear incentive
to wipe the decks
and remove your coach or let him know
that he's going to be gone at the end of
the season that's the other way that
allows you to do this
you've already got two teams that are in
the position to get the head start in
the jaguars and the raiders so
what do you want to do do you want to
start talking to these people do you
want to get to know them and if you're
encouraged
by
the league's enhancements of the rooney
rule
which are overdue and still not
sufficient
to do a broad search
and you have this head start
i i
i'm starting to wonder
if the bulk of the firings aren't going
to happen by next week and now what
helps some of these guys is they're
still alive like if you know if the
vikings do win tonight mike zimmer may
be out eventually anyway but if they win
tonight they're still alive for another
week or two oh yeah i think if they lose
they're still alive that's the problem
there's 28 teams still alive
so it wouldn't that be something if you
see a coach get fired by a team that is
still alive in the playoffs and the
interim coach would take them to the
playoffs i mean it could happen in this
in this environment because if you've
already made up your mind there's no
reason to wait until the end of the
season and there's every reason to
reason to implement soon so you can
start conducting those interviews
starting next monday merry christmas to
all the coaches who are about to get
fired this week well mike i mean we
almost saw that scenario in college
football albeit it was a coach leaving
of his own volition in notre dame you
know we almost had an interim head coach
coaching and a college football playoff
semifinal game you know i'm pleased to
say that it was my alma mater that
presented notre dame from having a seat
at that table but that's just me being
petty
don't don't open
a very old wound for me as it relates to
your alma mater
taking my
law school alma mater's coach and
putting ideas in his head when there was
a game that was still on the docket that
would have determined a spot in the
national championship
and his team was a 28 and a half point
favorite over pitt
and west virginia lost don't start no
don't start i got it it was 14 years ago
but i still remember it like it was
yesterday well i mean i i didn't i
didn't mean to shoot i'm just playing
with no no i i didn't mean to shake the
pit snoggle tree right there mike i mean
it's always kind of been there in
college
this is a new reality nfl and again i
don't think we understand what's about
to potentially happen
take care of yourself mike have a great
christmas with you and your family let's
do it again very soon thanks rich great
talking to you pal you're right back at
you that's mike florer everyone get his
book playmakers pre-order it right now
wherever you can get a a book certainly
in time for the holiday
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here